and i was a very sensitive kid um and i
felt like i had to hide that from a
really young age
and being disingenuous especially with
yourself like
it's growing up and not being able to be
yourself
is is unhealthy it's a really unhealthy
start because you're suppressing things
from the get-go
[Music]
my childhood growing up in hackney is
something i look back on fondly
um normally when i'm asked about it
people say well it must have been rough
it must have been difficult there were
difficulties
i was born into a household six of which
i was one of there was
me my mum her two brothers my nan nanny
pat and my great grandmother nanny edie
um bit by bit people started to leave my
mum was the first person to leave when i
was a year old
my dad was in and out my life i was a
really anxious kid and i think that
played
a huge part as to why i was so anxious
used to say to my
nan i got bellyache but it was just me
not having
the the tools or the language to say
that i was anxious
to me that not in my stomach which i now
know to be anxiety was a
pain it was man i've got tummy aches the
only way i could describe it
when i was 24 my dad
made an incredibly finite decision to
take his own life
which
at that point in my life like there's
there's no look there's not an easy way
for my man to have
abounded into my room and told me but
she just opened my door on a wednesday
morning
and said stephen your dad's dead he's
hung himself the first thing i did was
i remember punching the wall so angry
got up
walked to one of my friends built a
spliff tried to make sense of it and i
went through a whole spectrum
of emotions a whole array i went from
being angry to being upset
crying to to wondering and wanting to
know why he did what he did
how he could do it how he could be so
selfish that there's no getting away
from it he was a
father um but he was a really nice
person you know he was charming he was
funny he was loving he was kind
i came to the conclusion that the only
way i could ever truly understand how he
was able to do
what he did is if i was in the same
position and that's not a position that
i will ever be in
and that i guess began the journey
towards acceptance
and and to stop trying to
to understand you know the the wanting
to understand went on for a lot longer
than
the short snippet that i just gave you
but that constant wondering is not
healthy
i don't think mental health issues are
by any stretch
just a male problem but i think they are
a slightly different problem for men
because
it was difficult for me because i didn't
really have a dad to show me how to be a
man so i
you know i learned from probably quite a
few unhealthy places not least of all
the older kids in my flats
um but there's a lot of bravado you know
a lot of martialism and
with that comes this feeling of having
to suppress
anything that makes you
show any emotion that is in anger when
people think of men and emotions it's
not even emotions it's just
an emotion is anger and i was a very
sensitive kid
and i felt like i had to hide that from
a really young age and being
disingenuous especially with yourself
like it's growing up and not being able
to be yourself
is is unhealthy
it's it's a really unhealthy start
because you're suppressing things from
the get-go
it's called being sensitive but you have
to remember that you're resilient
where is illian is indian we survived
99.9
of everything that's chucked at us
because that's what we do
and the sad thing is you only learn that
you're resilient by suffering
learning that you can that you do that
you will survive is a very dangerous
thing
makes you a powerful person i guess it's
just about
getting to a place in life where you can
make an educated decision and hopefully
keep your heart open
enough to allow yourself to make some
mistakes even if that means you have to
make some of the same mistakes more than
once
rock bottom for me and i think it would
be the same for most people to be honest
is like
it's not it's not upset upsets rational
like if your cat dies you're upset
that's not depression
you know if you're sad or you're
overworked and you're tired then you
need a day in bed that's not depression
for me depression was always not really
feeling much of
anything and becoming quite
self-destructive
my music has been the biggest outlet for
absolutely
every struggle i've had to be honest um
and i think the same can be said for for
most artists
it's an incredible outlet there's a type
of therapy called cbt cognitive
behavioral therapy
and a cornerstone of that is something
called journaling which is
where you just write down what you think
uh what you observe or how you feel
at any given time which gives you
perspective because
how you feel on tuesday when you look
back at it on friday
might not be how you feel and you have
that perspective you're not just trying
to remember how you felt you've written
it down
with that i didn't realize that by way
of writing raps
um i was essentially journaling
and i think that's helped me to no end
because the artist that i used to
to love and still do to this day were
always the ones that put themselves in
their music and they spoke about what
they saw
and how they felt i'm honest about it
and so when i started writing music my
go-to was to talk about what i was
seeing
you know how i felt what i've been
through
and aspirational stuff where i wanted to
get to you know before i die i said
you know before i die i wanted god
bathtap so i haven't got there yet but
there are a couple of things on that
list in that song that i've ticked off
the single thing that i'm most proud of
is actually sticking with it
i never signed the deal that i signed to
virgin which would be where i'd sell
records for the first time until i was
27 without any plan b
i stopped going to school properly when
i was 13 i ended up in a pupil referral
unit despite being quite academic
and i even had friends of mine saying
come on bro you got to find something
else to do
you know i had a full start with mike
skinner's label when i was 21
we never got the album out napster came
out and warner withdrew all the
financing from their subsidiaries
of which the beats mike skinner's record
label was one of them
um i was in a legal battle with them
trying to get my records back from them
for over a year
but i stuck at it you know and i carried
on making music and
that sort of been the if there's any
one thing that i could say has got me
where i am or continues to see me get
anywhere
it's been the persistence you know a lot
of people just become angry because
something doesn't
work in their favor um things didn't
work in my favor
from a very young age so i had to learn
to become quite robust and resilient if
i wanted to do anything with myself
the fact that i found a way to use my
voice for something more than just my
own benefit
you know to become a mental health
advocate has been
fulfilling in a completely different way
and it's not without his challenges the
documentary work i did left me in a
really bad place because i spent four
years
living in the shoes of people who were
in terrible terrible terrible
circumstances
and knowing that every day when i finish
shooting and i go back to the hotel or
to my house or when i finish a program
and i go home those people are still
going through that
and they're a representation of a huge
part of our population you know the
social issues that
you know were a problem then and the sad
thing is is they're probably more
prevalent now than they were then all
these years on
because things don't seem to be getting
better they seem to be getting worse
and all too often people find themselves
in a position where they become
successful when they forget about
everything that should be important to
them because they only care about
themselves
there are several achievements that
people probably
imagine give you the feeling or the
security of having
made it but i don't i mean i don't think
you ever really have
because you want to constantly progress
you want to evolve
you know people think if i get a record
though i've made it you haven't that's
when the work starts
then you think okay if i get hit i've
made it you haven't that's when more
work starts
this ties into mental health in a way as
well because
if you're constantly moving the goal
post as far as like where you
put your happiness what will make you
happy
you're in a constant place of i mean if
you're not happy are you unhappy
you know i'll be happy if i sign a
record deal i'll be happy if
i sell x amount of records i'll be happy
if i sell x amount of tickets and then
what happens if you do that and then
you have to like start doing smaller
shows you know or if you put out single
it isn't
as big a hit as the last song that you
put out does that mean you're going to
be unhappy
it's it's an unhealthy way to think
about things
but i had the stupid idea you know if i
make it in music i'll be absolved of my
past
you know all the things that made me
anxious or unhappy or
upset would just disappear
um and then i became successful and
found that most of it was highlighted
and i was putting their magnifying glass
because i had to do interviews like this
one
which meant i was constantly talking
about it by
talking about things regularly they have
less power over you
so when i never used to talk about my
dad taking his own life if he ever come
up in conversation i get incredibly
upset
you know there was a point where i
hadn't seen his face for years and
i was at my dad's house with the girl
that i was seeing at the time
going through old photos and i saw a
photo of his and i just had to get up
and walk out the room because straight
away
it upset me it will always be sad what
my dad did
but i can for the most part talk about
things
you know quite in a quite relaxed
fashion without
engaging with those emotions and that's
not because i've become cold to it it's
because
i've become familiar with those feelings
and letting go is a part of of grieving
i think it's something that you it's a
point that you have to reach in order to
be able to to progress in your own life
and i'm at a point in my life now where
i've kind of worked out that it's not
healthy to look too far back or too far
forward otherwise it's impossible to be
present you can never enjoy you know
life where you're at at any given moment
and it's horrible to look back on
moments that you've not enjoyed because
you've either been worrying about what's
around the corner or
worrying about something that's already
happened that you have no control over
but it's a talent learning to not worry
about things that are out of your
control
and it's one that i'm slowly mastering
people ask me the last time i saw my dad
and
the proper answer to that is at my 18th
birthday
the other answer is i had a dream a
couple of years ago
um in which my dad was in and it was it
was odd i was
holding onto a kite and i was holding on
to it so tight the wind was so strong
and my dad was there all of a sudden um
and he said sometimes
it's it's easier to just let go
and uh he's he's not wrong
up until this point everything's okay
you know we go to the baggage
thing our bags ain't coming yeah
everybody else has got the bags right
and then
the police just come around with guns
and save tamira you
boom hands up in the air this and that
oh
no they're right now we're